Andy is with us in Kansas City
I'm Andy how are you hi Dave I'm great
in yourself better than a desert what's
up
wonderful so I have a dilemma I have a
job offer from another company that I
was not looking for and I don't know
what to do or even how to analyze
whether or not to take it and so I
called you and hoping you can give me
the correct guidance here we are in baby
step 2 and that's the biggest of my
hesitation is because we're down to the
last like eighteen thousand to pay off
and I'm like we're so close but it's
about eight thousand dollars more and
then it includes a $4,000 a year cash
bonus and so what would you do
so the new job offer offers you $8,000 a
year raise plus a four thousand dollar
bonus so $12,000 a year raise yes okay
what do you make now forty five thousand
okay is it in the same town do you have
to move it's actually closer and it's
about twenty minutes closer to home
that's nice too okay yes what do you do
now accounting for a nonprofit agency
and I have you know my own my own office
and I have you know just the nice
extreme flexible schedule whereas I'll
be going into a cubicles
but I'll still have a little bit of
flexibility okay I'm doing accounting
again yes doing accounting how old are
you I'm 29
okay when you're 49 and you look back on
the 20 years that you're getting ready
to roll from 29 to 49 what do you want
to have done what do you want to be
doing when you're 49 I want to be close
to being a CFO okay which is which of
these two offers takes you on that path
I think the new one because I know where
I'm at now we just hired somebody new
and say it's just me and this other
person but the pay is
we're near each other right okay so you
make more money you're closer to home
and it is on the track that you want to
go on as far as your career goes yes are
the people bad people at the new place
they're hilarious I mean I I enjoyed
meeting with them it's just like I've
been here I'm kind of like where I'm at
now I'm comfortable as been here and I
know all the infamouse no no but um so
far you've given me zero negative about
the new place the people are great it's
closer to home it's more money and it's
the path to where you want to go I'd be
learning a new job or like not because
it's the next step up in my career so
it's not really what you want to do you
don't want a peak at 29 you want to put
that off a couple days okay so it's a
little bit uncomfortable is the only
downside because you're going to be
doing new stuff new people a new
environment might be a little stress
involved with all that new new new
and you got your kind of kind of you
know you're kind of comfortable where
you are yes
fly Eagle okay fly Eagle don't sit in
the nest and be a turkey all right you
this is a Europe for this you can do it
everything you were looking for and
didn't even go looking for it I know
that's the craziest part I call that God
all right that's what I call that I
think God's showing up and going hey
Mandy
wink wink I got you you know and I think
yeah I don't think you walked past this
if you if you can find a negative to
throw in this discussion we'll talk
about it but so far I hadn't heard
anything negative except Mandy might be
uncomfortable a little bit while she
grows well get after it spud let's do it
all right you got this you can do it you
got the stuff kiddo study at I guess you
know there
so hey well done kiddo you got this very
cool proud of you